this album and also your documentary
um covers your relationship with camila
cabello i think so beautifully yeah it's
about you and i'm like everything is
about you it's always there
they've always been about you she goes
what do you mean i'm like like they're
all about you
like every song i've ever wrote who is
more mushy
when it comes to songwriting i think
we're both equally
very mushy and i think we're both
extremely mushy people
we're both super sensitive which is
creates a lot of sensitive sensitivity
in our relationship
but we are songwriters so we're
constantly searching for the sensitive
topics in the life
and um i don't know i'm pretty mushy i i
when i don't know what she wouldn't how
she went into that i feel like she would
maybe say i'm much more mushy
that's kind of cute though yeah are
there topics that you guys have both
agreed
to not write about when it comes to the
relationship
no we don't really put any rules or
boundaries i think on
our what we're writing about or our
art or even just i think i think the
truth about
being celebrities and being in a
relationship is that it's super tricky
because
there's a lot of people who want to know
more than maybe is
normal to give out they want more
personal stuff um
but both of us realize that like
it's just sometimes you you say
something that you maybe you shouldn't
have and sometimes someone asks you a
personal question you answer it because
you're off guard and
you know you can't really do much about
it it's just kind of the nature of the
beast
in uh in 24 hours it talks about how
fast
everything moved with camila is she your
forever person like do you talk about
an engagement one day yeah absolutely i
think
for me it's always been if i'm not
willing to talk about that stuff then i
kind of check out a little bit and um i
don't know i really think when you know
you know
and um she's been one of my best friends
since i was like 15 years old so
i don't know at the same time i know
we're really young so i don't want to
jump
like insanely fast but i think when you
find your person you feel and you know
that you found your person
what are you guys doing for the holidays
by the way i'm going uh back to canada
i'm going back home in five days
so much family time are you excited oh
my god we have a puppy
so and i'm going to my parents house so
camila and i are going to stay
in the basement at my parents house in
pickering ontario with a puppy it's
going to be super nice
that puppy is so cute by the way thanks
he's super cute
is it a lot of hard work it's like
having a baby it's like having a child
yeah well very good congratulations the
album is amazing
i'm so excited for you and for people to
hear thank you katie i appreciate you